you know adam you've kind of like done a
good job of like
turning no jumper into like a world i'm
trying man right like you know i feel
like it started off with just you you
being the guy who do who's doing a lot
of these early soundcloud interviews you
know what i'm saying like
um and
i feel like you kind of made a pivot in
the last like i was a year and a half
where you just kind of went all in on
like
building like a
a network award you know what i'm saying
yeah like a lot of effort used to go
into the store and i feel like you know
just dealing with the day-to-day chaos
of the store made it kind of hard for us
to like you know work on that but then
honestly it was a.d like when we brought
him in he was the first person i put on
camera that like really like
like got into it and was like kind of
hyped on doing podcasts and [ __ ] and i
think it was also the pandemic because
he normally would be off like doing a
lot more [ __ ] but he's kind of like you
know stuck in the crib a lot for a few
months there or whatever even though he
is realistically like the person who
ignored the pandemic more than anybody
oh for sure you never caught cover did
you
no well not talking i never we don't
know
money i think over here
ot would have it before anyone i knew
yeah bro i probably got it first and
didn't know by the time he came you know
what i'm saying yeah i remember we we
were talking about hotels like yo have
you not got coverage yet bro you're
[ __ ] everywhere like we got a good
squad now that we got dunno dude is
great
mm-hmm
uh sharp
pretty hyped on that
nah dunno is great working on some more
um t-rex the guy who used to roll with
tiger right
that's a that's a that's a pun play
brought him in yeah i'm saying shout out
to pun man bum ass rims
bum ass rams the rams they're uh they
lost to the cardinals in l.a shout out
tiny cur
hey so how does that work so like you
get your cut of like like you give him a
cut of his show or like how does how
does every is everyone taken care of
yeah yeah it's like percentages
everything handsomely nice i'm not
complaining
and then your show is called at the end
of the day on wednesdays um
formerly known as tales from the [ __ ]
no that's what he he might do his idea
for me to have a show was totally
different he wanted me to interview like
gang members old gang members from all
over he wanted you to be
the [ __ ] vlad basically
we was like nah [ __ ] i broke the light
the lane is wide open
really i was gonna let you do whatever
you wanted i just i don't know that was
like i was like you know you should talk
to like these g's that like other people
couldn't get on the podcast and it turns
out he would rather tell poop jokes with
juno and make fun of tyrell's arm and
whatnot but i mean you know
either way